you know I haven't even had a shower yet
I was gonna put part 7 in C as his own
video but I decided not to I just have
to put at the end of the full story
video so the Batman who lives
the full story okay
so we are picking up with the Batman who
laughs which is a miniseries this being
written right now is originally I
thought it was an ongoing series but
it's a mini series I don't really know
how you make an ongoing series out of
the Batman who lasts and yellow
character like him could only ever
really be like a mini or a maxi series
like 6 or 12 issues long but this is a
monthly series which means that we have
December in the January February March
April and May is when it concludes
assuming that they stick with a
six-issue format and there's no delays
having said that this character was
crazy popular and I knew like as soon as
Batman who last struck like Oh soon as
dark nights but will happen it was a
version of Batman who became the Joker
like I knew his only ever matter Tom
before we got a mini-series or something
like that because people loved it like I
mean you guys loved the idea of the
Batman who laughs I do this is amazing
but the other cool thing about this is
that this is kind of like a return to
form for Scott Snyder when it comes to
Batman not to say his Justice League is
bad or anything I love his Justice
League
I love the work that he's been doing so
far but to me Scott Snyder is is best
when he's on Batman because he just
writes the characters so well and so
what this does is this initially picks
up with a handful of guys who were
basically smuggling things out of Gotham
now this is the way Scott Snyder writes
Batman those of you guys who read his
new 52 runs so quarter bowels knight of
owls death of the family and in game
that a lot of us just kind of like
Batman being a detective while being a
hero at the same time they kind of
explain to you what's happening as it's
going on and what we end up learning
here is that among the various schemes
that different criminals have in Gotham
City that one of them involves smuggling
things out of out of town and into other
cities by way of using order basically
transport trucks these giant flatbeds
are designed for the purpose of moving
houses and you have we have these old
you know houses that are being moved out
of Gotham City in order to build condos
but what's been going on here is that
inside these flatbed trucks are like
these small little segments these small
little compartments they can be used to
house contraband and no one's the wiser
because as far as any cop looking at
them is concerned they're just moving
houses out there is removing houses to
make way for condos and and that's
really the end of that but where Batman
kind of shows up here it's really kind
of Batman par for the course where just
to say him going through and and
tracking these guys down talking to
Alfred on the other end and then
locating you know what's inside these
compartments what's basically here now
where Batman takes these guys out almost
right off the bat he in turn analyzes
the compartment figures out
where it's at and then basically cracks
it open and when he does there's
basically a kind of stasis pod of sorts
and inside this pod this casket is
basically a version of himself and
that's when things really begin to pop
off and that's when it gets cool when
you start to get in the introspective
stuff because that's what Schneider does
right I slide is like okay so business
as usual until it's not until like
things pop off and it starts to go crazy
and then you kind of have to figure out
what in the world is going on and so
what ends up happening here is where he
basically dresses up as like a board guy
and then going through and analyzing his
own body Batman he almost kind of has a
little bit of a crisis of self here
right like he looks at this whole thing
and he says okay so this is basically me
and Alfred has the hardest time grasping
this because remember Alfred is looking
at all this through the camera provided
by Batman on his on his own body as osan
like Alfred can see Bruce Wayne and then
the version of himself on the table for
Alfred he's looking at Bruce Wayne on
the table and not only that where they
start going through and they start
looking at this version of Bruce Wayne
they start seeing things where he's
basically the opposite of the main DC
universe Bruce you know these the
opposite of Bruce Wayne for rebirth in
the sense that this version of Bruce he
had a happy life and in a lot of ways it
almost kind of seems to be the life that
Bruce Wayne envies this version of Bruce
Wayne had wrinkles on his eyes which
indicated laughter he had a ring on his
finger he was married to Selina Kyle he
has a tattoo called May that's the name
that Bruce would have chosen had he and
Selina Kyle got married and had a child
this is one of those things where you
look at that and you say this Bruce came
from a perfect life basically he had the
perfect life
that somewhere along the line that he
has all the same scars as a DC rebirth
Bruce Wayne off to the point when he was
big when he basically had his back
broken by Bane and that seems to be the
change in in status quo right like in
the in the main DC Universe Bruce Wayne
fought against Bane right let you know
Bane was this guy from Santa Prisca
prison and he figured out Bruce Wayne's
identity is Batman in like three months
and basically instituted this this kind
of guerrilla warfare campaign and that's
when when he basically broke the back of
Batman and when he did it was expected
the Batman would be out of commission
instead Batman eventually took time to
recover and he ultimately went back to
being Batman again and this alternate
reality that doesn't seem to have been
the case that Bruce's back was broken by
Bane and then he just never went back to
being Batman he stayed as a person who
has essentially hands-off which kind of
begs the question what happened at
jean-paul Valley because in the time
when Bruce Wayne's back was broken and
the time he came back to being Batman
jean-paul Valley took up the mantle for
himself but you know this version of
Bruce from this alternate reality seems
to have taken up more of a human
in role he worked on civil projects
different things like that so he
accepted his fate with his back broken
and just kind of went forward
accordingly
somebody somewhere had basically killed
him and we don't know who it was
and so again it's it's kind of crazy
because this is the life that Bruce
always wanted no athene ever got and to
see it on the face of someone basically
meant that the life he had was
essentially taken away in a lot of ways
it's a personal loss here he found tried
and true happiness and he was yanked
away why like that's the question that
he wants the answer to more so from here
we switch over to Arkham Asylum we have
a couple guards running through and then
we have Batman who basically appears
here and it's kind of funny because in
this initial conversation between Bruce
and Alfred Bruce says you know where we
have to go we have to go see him and so
then we switch back over to Arkham and
then we essentially have like Batman go
on a warpath and start killing all these
guards
he's decked in guns he's got all kinds
of arms and armament the guy is loaded
for bear and this is something that we
don't normally see like you never see
Batman really use guns you do like once
in a blue moon but aside from the 1940s
late 1930s early 1940s during the Golden
Age when Batman did actually kill people
they usually use more for like fear
tactics is to show how extreme Batman is
at the time as opposed to the fact that
he would actually use it on a person but
going through and killing every last one
of these guards these guys are innocents
you know these guys are not people who
are inherently vindictive like they're
not people who are bad people they're
people with their own lives her own
family so on and so forth so this is a
merciless version of Batman he kills a
member of his own rogue's gallery he's
going through and it's literally a
one-man army from there he basically
breaks into one of the cells and freeze
the Joker at least it seems like he's
freeing the Joker that was kind of
interesting because from the Joker's
perspective it really is the arrival of
Bruce Wayne and Bruce Wayne snapped
right and as we know from The Killing
Joke it's like the one thing the Joker
always wanted to show Batman then all it
takes is one bad day to essentially kind
of snap to break and to become some sort
of villain and that's the de Joker's
mantra but on the other side of that
coin it's the thing that Joker doesn't
want the most The Joker needs Batman he
has to have him there without Batman
Joker's and complete he has no real
purpose Batman is the yin to Joker's
yang and so where he kind of taunted for
a second at least hawkster that says you
know are you here to kill me you know
somebody just says no instead the Batman
who last shows up and it's just like wow
as soon as I saw this always like holy
cow you know it is crazy because because
Joker starts begging for his life and
that's uh that's that's very
uncharacteristic of the Joker right like
the Joker never begged for his life the
Joker he would just start laughing
maniacally you know because well this is
the end of the Joker this is how it ends
almost as if it was kind of like some
ironic sad tale that the Joker always
imagined that Batman would be the one to
kill him and instead it ends up being a
Batman who lasts that's one thing to
bear in mind is that the Joker knows who
the Batman who lost is he knows who he's
about but before he even has a chance to
respond the Batman who lost smashes him
in the head without with a hatchet and
kills the Joker and it's just like wow
and so switching over to Batman
basically following up on the death of
the Joker this is what we ended up
learning it wasn't actually the Joker
now in reality this is an important
thing in reality if you're new to comic
books this would seem like well that's
dumb but in truth like this this is the
nature of the Joker right like this is
not so many scott Snyder's pulling out
of his backside he's not taking the
cheap way out did the Joker if he if he
senses that his end is coming if he
senses of somebody anybody besides
Batman is gonna kill him what he'll do
is you'll take one of his dummies and
he'll switch them out we've seen him do
that multiple times over the years so
again that's par for the course it's
like the coin of two-face is like big
gun of Victor fries it's just part of
the Joker's character as part of what he
does so that's a very important thing to
understand because it'll shift your
perspective on why this happened and why
it played out the way it did again it's
not Scott Snyder taking the easy way out
it's just the major of what the Joker
does constantly and so where Batman ends
up traveling back to the Batcave what he
ends up doing here is is basically
speaking with Alfred and saying you need
to open the door to the waterway and
when and when Alfred responds is one of
protests Batman's responses you have to
do this and that's what we end up
realizing that inside the waterway is
the actual Joker himself now there's a
reason why this happens so we need to
kind of jump all the way back to the new
52 really going forward from like death
of the family to endgame and the reason
why is because when it comes to Scott
Snyder is
storytelling a Batman it all feeds in
right like Scott Snyder kind of goes on
the assumption that you're familiar with
his Batman story is Batman run at the
start of new 52 in order to understand
what's going on now so to kind of
explain that um when the new 52 first
kicked off there was a single issue like
a like an annual or like a special or
something like that from a tech to
college that featured the Joker and then
we didn't we didn't hear from him for
like two years and it wasn't until death
of the family when the Joker returns but
you basically end up realizing the Joker
has been doing a lot of things behind
the scenes the Joker's been removing his
face and he basically has a kind of sewn
back on again he Institute's like the
systematic destruction of the Batman
family he goes through and he wages kind
of a one-man war against Batman which
culminates an endgame you learn things
like the Joker is essentially immortal
by consuming dionisije M different
things like that but one of the things
that Snyder establishes
is that in the early days of Bruce's
career is Batman between the time when
he was full-on Batman and the time that
there the Batcave was formed then what
had happened was he had basically face
off against the Joker
you know things he kind of got awry that
Joker seemed to have been defeated but
the Joker he basically stowed away and
followed Batman to the Batcave and
figured out where Batman resided and so
again it was it was kind of interesting
because that fed into death of the
family when the bat family realizes this
they realized that Joker's always know
where they operated out of and at any
point in time their identities could
have been leaked at any point in time
their personal lives could have been
destroyed and Batman didn't tell anyone
it was a betrayal of the bat family was
like the big betrayal the Batman hid the
fact that the Joker knows where the
Batcave is and so that's why this is
significant here is because it's like
the common meeting ground is the one
place Batman would expect the Joker to
show up if the Joker believed his life
was in danger and the Joker was looking
for some measure of safe haven and
that's what Batman tells him you're safe
here and and the Junkers I don't want to
be safe pulls a gun on Batman and hits
Joker in the heart and that's exactly
what the Joker was aiming for and what
is up happening here is the worst fear
of Batman exactly as it played out with
a Batman who last that would the Joker
dying the toxin in his chest begins to
leak out to infect the next person that
killed him to turn them into the Joker
and when that happens in infection
Batman and wouldn't infect Batman he
turns into the Batman who laughs and
when the questions asked why did Joker
do this the Joker said because you can't
stop him unless you become him okay so
we are continuing the Batman who laughs
miniseries and uh yeah okay I'm I'll be
honest man like let it sit the same
thing I said in the first in the first
issue like this is so cool and jock is
the one who okay so jock someone doing
the art those you guys don't know I'm
pretty sure jock was the one who did the
art for witches and if you guys never
read Scott Snyder switches you are
seriously missing out your Scout
Snyder's which is is ridiculously good I
can't wait to get into witches too but
it's it's it's pretty wild anyway so so
what are these to pick up on here and
kind of rehash because it's been a
little while been a few weeks since we
did the first one and we do a cert
catching up to do because I mean it is
January so was the time of year we just
kind of lay back and just do like three
videos a week or something like that
then we start picking things back up
again something once we get into like
February and March with this whole idea
the Batman who lost the Batman who last
was like the most popular character to
come out of Dark Knight's metal right
like I think we can all agree on that
but the Batman who last was just
resoundingly popular because there was
the answer to the question what would
happen if Batman became the Joker and
the idea
this is the Batman who last it always
has kind of been in the background
following Dark Knight's medal he was
never actually defeated and it wasn't
really until recently until this
miniseries but we actually have him
doing things he was kind of in the
beginning him of immoral men a little
bit but he was more in the beginning of
a mortal man for the purpose of like
drawing in leadership than actually
doing anything worthwhile but the long
and short of what we've seen so far just
in the first really the first a second
issue so far is that the Batman who last
has a plan we just don't know exactly
what it is but remember the entire basis
behind how the Batman who last became
what he was was when the Joker had
essentially been killed and then
released a kind of Joker toxin that
infected Bruce Wayne and turned him into
the Joker which turned him into the
Batman who laughs and so the idea is
that when Joker kind of appears to Bruce
Wayne at the end of the first issue and
then offs himself that is essentially
like okay the Joker's like you're the
only one who can defeat the Batman who
laughs you have to become me in order to
beat him and then Joker basically tries
to off himself in an effort to like
spread the toxin out the difference here
is that it doesn't happen right off the
bat because of the fact that that Bruce
Wayne is aware of who the Batman who
laughs is and the origin story of his
character he's trying to like stem the
flow and so what's basically going on
here is Bruce is kind of transforming
they're trying to keep it at bay while
at the same time the Joker's being
worked on if the Joker dies but that's
when the toxin really gets released and
there's no coming back but in this
instance what Bruce Wayne has been doing
is literally pumping himself with every
kind of Joker toxin they have but that's
one of the important things to bear in
mind here is that the toxin within the
Joker's heart is so potent that it can't
really be stuck all the other versions
of the Joker toxin that exists out there
those have antidotes right like that's
what Bruce Wayne's been using over the
years is using those antidotes to those
versions of the Joker toxin synthesizing
an antidote if the toxin is new and then
using it to cure people this is a
perfect strain it's a perfect and pure
strain and so there is no antidote for
there's no conceivable way to overcome
it and so the best that Bruce can do is
stave it off and so while that's
happening what he's trying to do here is
understand what the Batman who laughs is
trying to do and so in the midst of all
this while all that's going on what we
end up having is some guy who's driving
and suddenly like a version of Bruce
Wayne lands on top of his car now this
freeze in Commissioner Gordon and it
brings in what appears to be Harvey
Bullock now with Commissioner Gordon
he's kind of working on the other half
of this case or the first part of the
case kind of the front side is the
Batman who laughs is back what's his
plan the back side is all these
different versions of Bruce Wayne from
what are basically what seem to be like
the dark
tubers are popping up now that's kind of
the the caveat here is initially it
seemed to be dark multiverse versions of
Bruce Wayne this does not appear to be
true instead what it seems to be our
verses of Bruce from across the
multiverse not versions of Bruce Wayne
from the dark multiverse and the reason
why is because with that multiverse
itself it was basically full of what
like like worst-case scenarios what if
Superman became a bad guy and killed
everybody on earth
what if Batman became the Joker and then
became an evil version of Batman like
that's the kind of thing you see in the
dark multiverse this version of Bruce
like the other version who had died and
the other versions that have appeared
off panel that have been discovered by
Commissioner Gordon are good versions of
Bruce this one in particular was
actually mayor of Gotham City the
problem with this is that while all that
happens one of the rookies basically
walks up to Harvey Bullock starts
talking to him and Harvey Bullock starts
freaking out and that's when we end up
learning this is actually Bruce Wayne
with the Joker toxin and that's what's
so crazy about this is Bruce is walking
a knife's edge right now at any moment
he could fall over he could literally
flip over the other side and become the
Joker he's doing the best he can D to
kind of hold it together but there's a
limit to all this the other half and
this is this is one of the cool things
about Scott Snyder writing is Bruce
reveals something that we didn't really
know before and so one of the things he
does here is he draws what's basically
called the last laugh
and the idea was that if Gotham City
were ever attacked which is to say if it
was like a chemical weapon or if there
was some kind of toxin that was released
across the city or whatever it is but
the city itself just sort of fell into
absolute madness now there were all
these tunnels that have been designed
over the years they were basically allow
for for fast travel of like food and
supplies and means by which the city
could essentially be fixed but what
Bruce Wayne has been working on is his
own version of last life because the
fact that the Joker toxin is so so
powerful and presumably coming out of
the events of Batman in Game one of the
things that Bruce Wayne devised is that
there had to be a means by which the
city could be cured he could literally
pump an antidote into the entire city
itself and cure everyone and so by
working on that one of the things he
says is that this is a system by which
Gotham can be saved but it's also a
system by which Gotham can be destroyed
and the initial response of Commissioner
Gordon is well then what's the huge
concern here and the response to Bruce
Wayne is to say that you can only access
it using DNA and that's when we pick up
with the Batman whoo laughs and that's
what's so great about this is because
the Batman who laughs is an evil version
of Bruce he essentially had all the same
experiences as Bruce Wayne up into the
point when the Joker died and he was hit
with the toxin and then went crazy and
so because he thinks he feels he
functions in the exact
way as Bruce Wayne in the main DC
Universe he would do the exact same
things Bruce would which means he's he's
aware of the exact same things Bruce's
and so that's when really Snyder kind of
tells us indirectly that all these
things that Bruce Wayne's doing in the
main DC Universe the Batman who lasted
in his universe and so with that
happening with that in mind Batman who
last shows up at Wayne Manor which is
the only access point to this last laugh
tunnel that Bruce Wayne's been building
and then in turn basically begins to
access it now the only real guardian
here is a guy named Bill and the initial
inclination is like how does Bill not
know this is Bruce Wayne
only for us to find out that Bill's
blind as it was kind of a cool thing
because what this would do is it would
actually allow Bruce Wayne to access
this aspect of Wayne tower and for Bill
to never really know Bruce Wayne's face
or at least to never really know that it
was actually him now the fact that Bill
refers to him as mr. Wayne indicates
that Bill knows exactly who Bruce Wayne
is and the Batman who last makes his way
in there and what he does we see an
aspect of his character we don't
normally see when it comes to this
version of Bruce and when we saw him in
Dark Knight's metal he was really more
like the second-in-command he was a guy
who was running alongside Barbados but
when you throw him into the story what
it does is it shows he's just as capable
as we would expect it's all the
formidable formidable abilities of Bruce
Wayne combined with the insanity of the
Joker which basically makes for him
going through and killing every single
member of Wayne security inside this
section of Wayne Tower with no limits
whatsoever one of the other cool things
here and it really kind of underscore
the fact that he and Bruce thinks so
much alike is that once all these guys
are dead he counts down and three two
one
BAM enters Batman and that's kind of the
cool thing here is because what it means
and what it really shows here is that
ruse Wayne fighting this evil version of
himself that it really seems to be an
even match and in fact as this fight
unfolds Bruce comments on it proper that
he says well I'm stronger but I'm not
faster and so because of the fact that
he's able to fight so capably what this
means is he can overcome me because of
the fact that he knows exactly how I
function he knows the weaknesses he
knows what kind of weapons he needs in
order to overcome my various suits of
armor and the kind of defense mechanisms
that I employ and it's kind of a funny
thing here because Bruce gets the upper
hand on the Batman who lasts and when
Bruce kind of basically says like your
whole plan stops here the response about
I knew last is what makes you think this
is not part of my plan and that's the
cool that's what I loved so much about
his character it is Scott Snyder writes
them in such a way that you have to
assume everything that happens happens
according to the will of the Batman who
lasts that if he's defeated is because
he wanted
to be defeated because he wanted to be
taken to a particular location and he
knew he would be taken to that location
if he was defeated because he knows how
Batman works as a you have to assume
that he knows everything that's going to
happen or at the very least has planned
it all out ahead of time and this all
really comes to a head when Bruce Wayne
is shot and this is cool because what
that man who laughs does as he says
there's basically this guy out there
this version of Bruce Wayne who's out
there
he's called the grim Knight he's
basically Batman as the Punisher that
this version of Bruce Wayne is far more
extreme and the way he came into
existence was by virtue of the fact that
when Joe chills shot Thomas and Martha
Bruce Wayne picked up a gun and shot Joe
Chill the implication seems to be that
Joe Chill shot Thomas and Martha and
then dropped the gun out of perhaps
panic or fear whatever the case was and
ran and in that moment Bruce Wayne
picked the gun up and shot Joe Chill and
that set him on the path of killing
every criminal he finds and so what that
man who lasts does does kind of reveal
everything to Bruce and say you built
this entire place in order to ensure
that Gotham could be saved in the event
of an emergency by pumping out some
antidote how many uses as a means to
destroy the city and the response of
ruse is well you can't do that because
the building can only really be used in
that regard if it's empty and the
response about and he lashes I know
and all these safeguards that you have
in place have all been dismantled by the
Grimm Knight he's done it all over the
pillow over the last couple days so I'm
going to destroy this building I'm to
destroy your ability to basically save
the city of Gotham in this moment
there's nothing that can be done there's
nothing Bruce Wayne can do the best you
can do is escape he grabs bill he uses
one of those little grappling hooks they
escape they escape Wayne Tower and the
entire building comes crashing down
around them and so what this means is
the means by which Gotham can be saved
based on whatever plan the Batman who
last has is gone there's no real way to
believe that it can be done in any real
measure of time because you have to
assume that whatever planet is the
Batman who last has whatever plan he has
has base is going to be predicated on
what Bruce Wayne would most likely do so
again overcoming the odds by knowing how
his enemy functions and so with Bruce
Wayne returning back to to Wayne Manor
and running up to Alfred its wick the
Joker up you have to wake him up now
what we end up realizing here is Joker's
been awake the entire time he's been
listening to the discussions of Bruce
and Alfred and where he's been kind of
laughing and they've been assuming it's
a reaction in reality he's laughing at
the futility of their choices he's
laughing at the futility of their
efforts to try to stop the Batman who
lasts because the responsive you know
really with Bruce here the idea is
you have to know the answer you have to
know what it is that the man who last
wants he's basically you from an
alternate reality only you really seem
to be the one that knows how his mind
works tell me what he's going to do and
the response to the Joker is I don't
know what he's gonna do there's only one
person out there in the entire world who
knows exactly what it is a Batman who
last is going to do and that person is
none other than James Gordon jr. the son
of Commissioner Gordon and the guy who's
basically nuts okay so we are uploading
this kind of late
um because I just got back from Disney
World I had an amazing trip it was
awesome I probably have a video about it
on my vlogging channel but we are
covering the Batman who laughs part
three and in the last video we basically
picked up with essentially the return of
James Gordon jr. now James Gordon jr. is
the son of Commissioner Gordon of James
Gordon and of course the brother of
Barbara Gordon Batgirl but the cool
thing about James Gordon jr. is that
he's imagine the Joker if he was
rational which I know kind of takes away
from the premise of like a psychopath
but when it comes to James Gordon jr.
he's one of these guys where all he did
was like think and plan ways to like
wipe out people destroy things cause as
much like you know pandemonium and chaos
is he possibly could and so because that
of course he was basically in prison and
of course he was put in a program where
it was basically a a drug that was
produced by Wayne pharmaceuticals that
could essentially cure a person who was
a psychopath and if I were correctly
from Batman eternal and from forever
evil the idea was to test the drug on
James Gordon jr. to see if it would work
on like the Joker or somebody like that
he was kind of a test subject more or
less but for the most part it's been
working while he takes two shots a day
like test his blood you know to make
sure that everything's still in effect
and so on and so forth he gets kind of
nuts in terms of how he how he lives his
life but it's super super strict to make
sure he doesn't go back to doing what he
was doing before but the idea behind
this is you know for those guys who were
catching up the idea behind this was
that the Joker when he was taken
prisoner by Batman I really kind of
brought in by Batman and then so on
everything kind of unfolded is that
James Gordon jr. is the key to stopping
the Batman who lasts and we didn't
really know how far this key extended
right like we really know what doors it
unlocked but that's essentially what
this kind of does when you have James
Gordon meeting with his son it's really
kind of Scott Snyder giving us this
refresher and say here's what James has
been doing but then of course the group
is met with the arrival of Batman and
this is when things get kind of cool
because what Bruce says under normal
circumstances when Bruce Wayne
approaches someone
yes he watched them for a particular
purpose but he wants to make sure the
things stay on the up-and-up when he
approaches James Gordon jr. what he says
is I don't want the version that's doing
what he's supposed to do like I don't
want the one who's a good guy
I want the murderer like I want the
murderer of the killer that could a
crazy psychopath that's the version that
I want and the whole idea behind this is
as Batman explains is that the Batman
who lies is implementing a plan to
essentially like to destroy Gotham now
we don't know exactly what this plan is
in its entirety we just know like the
Batman who last wants to unleash
pandemonium and chaos and the way this
Snyder plays this out is it looks like
it'll be something that's far more
extreme than like Batman in game those
you guys you never read Batman in game
what we ended up finding out was the
Joker had this plan to assist release
Joker toxin across the entire city of
Gotham and to send the city into like
like mass hysteria and in like you know
chaos and and panic and so on and so
forth and it worked he actually did it
like it was it was kind of nuts the way
it all played out
but of course with Batman using the last
laugh plan which was essentially using
like the tunnels of Gotham to
essentially pump out like a cure to the
Joker toxin we're all that's kind of out
the window now the idea is to know what
the joke what the Batman who last plan
is going to be and because James Gordon
jr. is a legitimate psychopath who spent
a majority of his life just like
analyzing and trying to find ways to
destroy things
he's the best person to go to because
right now they can't really they can't
get answers from the Joker it was kind
of cool because what this is is an act
of desperation
while James Gordon jr. is a psychopath
he's not exactly like the Batman who
lost the Batman who last is a
combination of the Joker and Batman it's
an answer to the question what would
happen if Batman became the Joker and so
the best person to go to is the Joker
but the Joker is not spilling the beans
he's not giving any real answer and the
only answer he did give is go find James
Gordon jr. he's the answer you were
looking for and so that's literally why
Batman's following these breadcrumbs and
following these directions is because
he's a really have a choice here it's
kind of funny because James Gordon jr.
does not want to do any of this stuff
James Gordon jr. is like I don't want to
do this like I do not want to jump into
this scenario again I don't want to go
back to being that version of myself so
he's very much against the idea which
really kind of ties Batman's hands and
so when they try to reason with him and
they say like put down the scanner and
and like talk to us he says like I'm not
the one with this red dot meaning
somebody's targeting them and that's
whenever when when like all hell starts
to break loose because of course the
group is met by the arrival of what's
basically Punisher Batman and this is
cool because Punisher Batman and like
Batman himself actually face off against
each other it's basically a guy who's
shooting to kill
versus a guy who's not and they're able
to like dodge the attacks of each other
so for the most part it's it's a
stalemate insofar as one of them kind of
gets the upper hand yo Batman kind of
gets the upper hand on Punisher Batman
but not really and the reason why is
because we're Punisher Batman it's kind
of caught unawares we're like a
grappling hook and basically kind of
left dangling over over a bridge and
whatnot you end up having him basically
like bringing all these different
vehicles and so on and then say like
there's a jet flying above us and if you
do not give me James Gordon I'm gonna
destroy the jet I'm gonna destroy one of
its one of its uh one of its engines
this is cool because what this does is
it again hints at the idea and really
kind of point to the idea of how capable
this evil alternate reality version of
Batman is but in his universe there are
no villains there's no Joker no
scarecrow no penguin no two-face no
nothing he's killed them all that he has
basically gone through and like Isis
like controls the entire city of Gotham
right even hits it like no hits home at
what he calls the colony and so that's
really kind of Scott Snyder basically
bringing in the idea of like Tom King
and James tan Ian's Batman runt
or Batman Detective Comics run when you
have the colony right like this
organization that essentially kind of
took over a kind of a paramilitary group
the father of that woman who took over
it wanted to take over Gotham City
and then like basically weaponized
Batman's technology to essentially
control the city of Gotham and then
alternate reality this Punisher Batman
has done that and so being that capable
he's basically began colonizing Gotham
City in like the main DC Universe by
basically saying like I know everything
that's going on everywhere at least you
know I'm getting to the point where I am
and so him basically saying like if you
don't do what I tell you to then I'm
going to take out this plane 72 people
are going to die 41 of them are
Gothamites I'm gonna kill them all all
you have to do is give me Commissioner
Gordon and it all goes away
and work where Gordon is kind of like
where he believes it is his son that
he's talking about the response about
man is it's not the Sun it's you and he
literally knocks out Commissioner Gordon
and hands him over to like Punisher
Batman and the idea behind this at least
you know in terms of why this is being
done his Batman says that when it came
to like the whole last laugh device that
he had the device it would serve the
purpose of like allowing a cure to be
implemented throughout the city of
Gotham required like a two-point
activation it required Batman and
someone he trusted the only person he
really trusts being Commissioner Gordon
now switching over to the iceberg lounge
to - penguin it's kind of cool here
because of course the Batman who laughs
basically busts in and starts torching
the place literally using the various
weapons and gimmicks of the Joker I'm
sorry of penguin
to start tearing everything up is sort
everything is setting everything on fire
now some of the gimmicks that really
seem to be brought here by Batman who
laughs seem to be gimmicks from his own
universe which is to say like one of the
I guess you know an umbrella of the
penguin that can shoot alcohol which in
turn if given a flame can set everything
on fire just small little things like
that that are that are really
interesting and really really smart for
him to use in this scenario by literally
taking out all the forces of penguin and
then bringing in another version of
Bruce Wayne and in his alternate reality
version of Bruce this is a version that
actually tried to reason with the
penguin they tried to like work
alongside the penguin and actually
became a criminal lord himself and then
rose to power and gain more powers in
the penguin did and then the tables
turned so that when penguin was
basically losing all of his clout all
this power and all this money he tried
to reason with his version of Bruce but
was always pushed out so this version of
Bruce Wayne is basically a mob boss and
it's kind of cool to see like he's dark
he's sinister and it's interesting to
see that happen because of course the
Batman who lasts kills that version of
Bruce and then tells tells penguin if
what you're looking for is the person
who basically set all this in motion a
person who seems to be like skewing your
dice to where is taking away the effect
of like the house rigging the games and
so on and so forth then go talk to one
your guys name matches Malone now those
guys who don't know matches Malone is
the colonel underworld identity of Bruce
Wayne he uses the name matches Malone to
infiltrate the criminal underworld so no
one really knows that he's actually
Bruce Wayne it's a long-standing secret
identity it's one of those those little
Easter eggs and hallmarks the fans love
seeing brought up all over the place but
it's a cool little thing here because
what Batman who laughs does is basically
send penguin on the trail of matches
Malone now that probably won't come to
fruition for quite some time but what it
does mean is that somewhere later on
around the corner presumably when Scott
Snyder starts riding into other Batman
stories and so on that penguin will
start looking for matches Malone
all the while totally unaware of the
fact that he's basically tracking down
Batman and just not knowing him so it's
kind of cool here because what is up
happening is that when Batman basically
gets James Gordon jr. back to the
waterways and says hey look I need you
to look at everything here and use your
psychopathic intelligent mind to figure
out what's the best way to spread some
toxin around Gotham and like destroy the
entire city James Gordon jr. initially
begins to kind of bend and say okay but
then he asks a question he says like
tell me one thing did docker get to you
did the Joker get you an Joker infect
you because if he did that's the key to
the plan there's nothing I can really do
here if anything I'm like a stopgap
measure you know I can't really do a
whole lot of things here like there's
not a whole lot that I can that I can
offer in this scenario
he does what he can but like that's
really yet but in the middle of it all
suddenly like Alfred pops up the back
came has basically been trashed the
Joker's literally like he's got his
heart like his chest is open he's got
his heart sitting there he's been riding
hahaha in blood all over the place like
it's absolutely bonkers and so so what
is up happening is like when the
questions asked by James Gordon jr. what
do we do next
Batman says we do the only thing we can
do the one thing that we should have
been doing the entire time the one thing
the Joker told me to do at the beginning
of all this
the one thing everybody's been telling
me all this time the one thing that I
was supposed to do this whole time and
never really wanted to do in the first
place
and so what ends up happening here is
that when Alfred finally makes his way
back to the Batcave and then finding out
that he cannot access the the proper
location and then has to go to like one
of the exterior entrances when he gets
down there we end up finding out that
what Batman's done has removed all the
toxin all the toxin blocks from his body
and totally given in to like the Joker
serum this is the only plan that I have
I have to become the Batman who laughs I
have to become this version of the
character in order to be able to defeat
him crazy okay so I just saw best man
like I was just watching best man with
Mariah that movie's really good or
actually I'm ready to watch the second
one but I have to record this audio I
recorded it the first time and it turns
out I recorded it to the bike the
microphone on my on my laptop on my Mac
Pro and so I screwed it up anyway okay
so getting into Batman the the grim
light this is actually kind of
interesting because Snyder usually plays
these things pretty close to the vest
and it's kind of a change of pace to
introduce like a one shot I mean he did
that with like the origins of the the
various you know villains from Dark
Knight's metal so I guess it kind of
makes sense to keep the trend going but
before that there weren't really any one
shots right like court of owls Knight of
owls in game death of the family it was
all kind of contained and like the
particular run so this is kind of a cool
maneuver here and I'm really interested
to see where it goes but what this does
is it initially picks up with basically
Punisher Batman I'm calling her calling
um Punisher Batman because that's
basically what he is but the cool thing
about this is that this initially picks
up with like the death of Bruce Wayne's
family now of course this is kind of a
hallmark of the character it's like
Krypton exploding for Superman and the
idea is that under normal circumstances
in the main DC Universe
Bruce Wayne was just kind of left there
right like Joe Chill pulled the trigger
killed his parents and then ran and that
was kind of the end of that and then of
course it was Bruce Wayne basically
saying like I'm gonna swear vengeance so
this never has to happen on anybody else
again or anything along those lines but
in this instance this is not what
happens instead Bruce basically
experiences like this rush of anger and
here and in doing so picks up the gun
turns it on Joe Chill and shoots him now
this is kind of a cool thing because
what this does is it Simms them down the
pathway of becoming this dark and evil
version of Batman now one of the
important things to bear in mind here is
how this kind of feeds into like the no
kill rule right like it's not really a
hard and fast rule it's not like it was
established in a particular comic that
Batman will kill no more it was just
kind of a gradual series of events that
led to a sort of editorial decision made
by DC the Batman won't use guns anymore
but the overall gist in terms of why
this exists and how it was kind of
explained with regards to the Batman
mythos was twofold the first is that
guns are so final you pull a gun you
shoot someone there's no undoing that
right like you can't come back from that
you can't undo it that's Batman's
perception but at the same time the
other reason why Batman really kind of
steers away from guns is because guns
kind of hold a particularly iconic role
in his life because that's what killed
his parents and so the idea so always
basically stay away from that concept
and then of course use the role as
Batman to try to save as many people as
possible but following this whole thing
with his with his parents basically
dying and him shooting Joe Chill what it
does is it almost kind of mirrors Batman
year one by Frank Miller which is a
retelling of his origin in the
post-crisis landscape and so what you
have here where he's like breaking you
know breaking bricks and where he's like
kicking a tree and everything's like
that those are all basically like homage
'as to to Batman year one those are
scenes from that comic but the kind of
difference here is that where all that
training was done by Batman traveling
the world learning all these different
forms of martial arts learning espionage
and stealth and all that kind of stuff
training with like ninja clans or
different things like that where all
that was geared towards using all that
for the purpose of instilling fear and
then using that fear to prevent a crew
or to eliminate a criminal element in
Gotham this version of Batman is using
it to kill now again one of the big ways
they kind of pay homage to the old
Batman origin story is that in that old
story you had like a bat that flew
through the window writing it was kind
of one of those hallmark moments of
Batman's origin stories a bat flies
through the window and then it crashes
and then Bruce looks at it and says yes
father you know I will become fear I'll
become Batman the same thing kind of
happens here except Bruce Wayne shoots
it and says that's the idea I'll become
fear I'll basically become a bat in
order to eliminate the criminal element
in Gotham and one of the first things he
does is he goes to like this mob house
and basically kills everyone right like
he literally like kicks over this this
fire stamp of this fire pit and then
like burns the whole place down and like
burns all these people alive it's
cutthroat
and so what this does is it really kind
of skips forward a little bit but one of
the things that the Grimm night says is
that there's really no version of the
Joker in the universe he comes from but
the reason why is because in the early
days of his criminal element he killed
the Joker at Ace Chemical that in the
early days Batman essentially took out
like the Red Hood who would become the
Joker
he took out Killer Croc he took out the
penguin all these different guys so you
took out all these different criminals
right in the very very early days and
what this is done or at least what it
did is it kind of turned him into an
extreme vigilante that was being tracked
down by the Gotham City Police
Department but in this instance where
he's a he's a pure like a pure
dyed-in-the-wool killer it's one of
these things were like the the the only
real consent concept here is the moral
incorrupt ability of Commissioner Gordon
that it seems like in every single
universe as a commissioner gordon's in
he all he's always a good guy he always
has like this moral compass it's one
thing you can't betray you know you
don't kill people without without any
kind of recourse or anything like that
but at the same time it's actually a
pretty cool scenario because the great
thing about the Punisher Batman evade
the great thing about the fact that he
kind of takes along to his own hands and
kills all these criminals is he's really
just kind of saying hey look the justice
system had the opportunity to ensure
these guys wouldn't be released again
but because the nature of the justice
system is all about giving second
chances what it does is it basically
says hey look yes you're criminals we're
gonna give you opportunities to continue
committing crime Batman's a Batman
stance is I'm taking those opportunities
away the criminal justice system is
basically a means by which you can
escape your guilt and then in turn do
the exact same thing over again and
they'll always be a lawyer somewhere to
get you off they're not doing any good
for anybody and so it's a it's a pretty
cool concept here and it actually works
exceedingly well and so what you
literally have this funny scenario where
Commissioner Gordon tries to draw Batman
out this is one of the cool things about
this he tries to draw Batman out and in
doing so quote-unquote captures him well
the funny thing is is that Gordon
basically says like all this stuff is
controlled by Wayne Enterprises all the
while never realizing that the Batman
that the grim Knight is Bruce Wayne now
this is one of the big differences
between the grim Knight and the actual
Batman from idiot from the DC Universe
because the grim Knight exists to
eliminate crime everywhere he finds it
and because he's so effective at it he
had to believe that somewhere along the
line criminals would get their hands on
Wayne tech Wayne tech you know Wayne
tech you know weapons and equipment
different things like that it's a what
better way to kind of continue the war
on that criminal element and destroy it
damn I basically saying hey
were effectively gonna turn Wayne
Enterprises tech into like a two-way
street that while they use it for their
own ends I can control it from the back
end and that's exactly what happens
using his access to Wayne technology all
the guards are taken out like they're
all like all these cops are eliminated
on the spot that literally like this
this kind of fight breaks out between
Jim Gordon in Batman but of course
Batman basically ends up making his
escape and Jim Gordon's kind of left
with it with this information that was
kind of brought to his attention or at
least from the the ramblings of the
Batman who last that he can essentially
access Wayne technology now putting two
and two together
because Wayne technology is so advanced
and because my technology is not
something that's just easily accessible
from the backend what it means is the
only one who could really be able to
access it is Bruce Wayne and so what
ends up happening here is Commissioner
Gordon essentially draws the parallel he
draws a conclusion that Batman is Bruce
Wayne and in doing so basically says
he's public enemy number one for it for
Gotham City and where he goes to guys
like Rupert thorne who under normal
circumstances in the DC Universe are
villains and where he goes to guys like
two-face who are usually villains but in
this instance are actually like mayor's
you know that they they hold powerful
positions in the city of Gotham but
they're not criminals because why would
you want to be a criminal in the city of
Gotham when he got Batman killing all
the criminals he finds that what he
basically you know what Commissioner
Gordon says is like we have to track
this guy down we have to capture Bruce
Wayne I've got the backing of the FBI
either you can join me in this or you
can be left behind as well as one of
those things where the krita know that
that element kind of stays hands off the
FBI shows out to Wayne Manor alongside
Commissioner Gordon and they basically
call Bruce Wayne out and it's kind of a
cool thing because like this knock-down
drag-out fight happens between the two
but it's kind of a funny scenario here
is because under normal circumstances
and it's it's sort of strange that it
works out this way under normal
circumstances Commissioner Gordon should
never been able to get the upper hand on
Bruce Wayne because Bruce Wayne is just
such an effective fighter right like you
know hardcore Batman fans will say
that's ridiculous you know but my answer
to this is that most likely Commissioner
Gordon got the upper hand because he has
prep time you know I mean if prep time
works your Batman prep time works for
everything else and so Commissioner
Gordon gets the upper hand for a prep
time
I actually have no idea that's the
answer or not it's kind of strange I
mean technically speaking it shouldn't
really happen which is kind of a an
interesting concept an interesting idea
I'd really like to believe that one of
the one of the reasons why Commissioner
Gordon was kind of able to get the upper
hand on really the grim Knight is
because of the fact that the grim Knight
doesn't really rely
on stealth and and martial arts and
things like that in the same capacity
that Batman from the main DC Universe
does bitties more of just like a like a
broadsword right there just like this
this thing that just kind of SWAT you
know just swings and just is dying to
take out huge swaths of enemies whereas
the main DC Batman is more like a
scalpel he's more like surgical
precision that's kind of kind of his
whole MO and so that more likely more or
less more likely kind of seems to be the
way in which would happen but what it
did is it created a kind of animosity
between the grim Knight and Commissioner
Gordon the issue with this is that we're
not really told what happened with it
could with Commissioner Gordon in like
the dark multiverse we don't really know
what happened to it we don't know if he
died we don't know if like somebody took
place they kept the grim Knight from
being able to enact his revenge and the
reason why is because once he's here he
intends to basically enact revenge on
the main DC Commissioner Gordon that he
wanted to on the dark multiverse
Commissioner Gordon he associated wants
to like kill him on the spot but the
funny thing about this is that the
Batman who lasts basically says like
that's kind of pointless here we can do
much much worse to this guy than just
kill him if we kill him it's an easy way
out if we kill him then like he doesn't
suffer anymore but if you truly want him
to suffer then give it time let's
implement our plan and let's bring down
everything around him it's kind of a
cool thing because what this does is it
sort of kind of hits to the idea that
what we could be seeing is something
akin to like a return to The Killing
Joke right like we you see like
Commissioner Gordon being torture with
all these images of his daughter being
violated in different things like that
we don't really know okay what's going
on guys we are continuing the Batman who
laughs and I love you guys can tell but
I am not feeling very good right now
what to Wrestlemania which was awesome
got caught in the rain storm afterwards
which was not awesome and so for the
last couple of days I have had like a
stuffy nose on a sore throat and I've
been coughing up some delicious lung
butter I am under the weather so videos
will be scant this week ah there's this
video today they'll probably one on
Saturday and then we'll have like a
video on Monday I think
and then hopefully by Monday we'll be
back like hopefully by the weekend I'll
be feeling better we can you like get
back to normal uploads if not all
they'll be scant until I feel better so
anyway uh Batman who last part for okay
so this story actually kind of takes it
in same turn and it's kind of funny
because people were kind of getting a
little irritated it was taking so long
to come out but one of the things you
guys need to bear in mind is that DC's
actually slowed down their releases
they've decreased the number of books
that are coming out and they've also
slowed down how often those books are
coming out so it's one of those things
like sure they're trying to sort of
navigate the waters on
how come a book should be distributed
and so on it's always an ongoing process
it always happens every I don't know
every 5 to 10 years you know it's always
something along those lines that sort of
sees a shift but the fact remains that
that initially where this picks up and
it's kind of cool is remember Batman had
basically ingested like the Joker toxin
right like turned himself into the
Batman who lasts because from his
perspective and the advice of everybody
around him it was the only way he could
really win and so one of the things that
it kind of does is that with him sort of
ingesting this this substance and then
going through and kind of musing to us
for a minute one of the things that he
says is that when he is whatever he's
going through and things get tough right
like things get hard what he tries to do
is see the world through the eyes of
like the Robbins of of Jason Todd and
Tim Drake and and Dick Grayson and
Damian Wayne now he says seeing the
world through the eyes of the Robbins
but he refers to them as his children
and so really seeing the world through
their eyes kind of allowed Batman to see
innocence to sort of move away from the
perspective of like the world is dark
and dreary and everybody's bad and
seeing it from the perspective of hey
like sometimes people just trying to do
their best but like not everything is so
so black and white as adults really tend
to see it there's a lot of different
shades of gray there cause it was kind
of cool because following this you
basically pick out with Alfred who's
just now realizing what Batman has done
and this is actually a really really
cool exchange and the way the Scott
Snyder does this is really nothing short
of amazing because the way this plays
out is Alfred freaks like Alfred panics
right because for Alfred is like one of
the worst case scenarios and really
contextual II speaking given the current
situation it is the worst case scenario
Alfred Sphere is that Batman will be
lost forever that's the biggest thing
that he goes through and literally like
Batman says hey look I have this visor
on because it allows me to differentiate
things that was kind of cool because
initially we didn't really know what the
function of the visor of the Batman who
lasts we don't really know what his
purpose was honestly I always thought it
was just kind of for visual effect and
what Batman actually tells us really
Scott Snyder kind of says here is that
the visor serves a purpose that what it
does is it kind of allows the Batman who
lost to filter through all the different
wants and desires that people have but a
person can use it for a variety of
different ways the Batman who last uses
it in order to determine what people's
most violent desires are Batman can use
it to see what they're hopeful desires
are so busy kind of allows you to see
the the desires the wants the needs of
anybody that you look at and so when
it's taken away from Batman it's kind of
like his only real weapon but from the
perspective of Alfred it's like we'll
know I'm trying to keep you from
completing your desire to be the Batman
who lasts like it's not a really a thing
that you need
the thing that you want because you're
becoming the Batman who last and it's
kind of a cool thing because where
Batman tries to reason with Alfred
Alfred and turned like smack him across
the head with it and this is cool
because what it does is it turns into a
knock-down drag-out fight between Alfred
and Batman as this plays out like
literally Alfred is beating the crab
like beating the crap out of Batman and
then Batman just not doing anything to
stop him because he knows that the
reality of this is that it's kind of
coming from a place of love but as he
looks at bat looks at Alfred what he
sees is that where Alfred says hey look
I love you he sees like you know kind of
what the the venom is wanting him to see
which is Alfred wants to hurt you he
wants to bring you harm you have to get
rid of him you have to kill him and it's
kind of crazy because he sort of goes
are like this rant and tears Alfred down
where he's like all you've ever done is
pulled me back I've carried you all this
time like literally spewing out every
ounce of vindictiveness and anger that
he possibly could and that's really kind
of the nature of the toxin is that while
it sort of twists you out as a person
and it really kind of kind of real warps
your perspective it brings out all this
anger and all this wrath because in
reality it's almost like Batman's being
deprived of something that he feels he
needs one of the things that I hope you
guys are noticing here is this really
seems to be a pretty strong allegory for
like drug addiction and is it is kind of
crazy when you look at it that way like
we just sort of shifted up drug
addiction alcoholism things like that
like things that people are addicted to
that negatively impact themselves and
the people around them and that's why
it's kind of crazy because Batman's kind
of lashing out at Alfred like you don't
want me to succeed you don't want me to
bid if you want me to do well all you
want to do is pull me back you know and
all these different kinds of things just
spewing out anger but it's not really
Batman talking it's literally the the
talk should kind of talk to you through
Batman it's driving his mind to a place
then it doesn't really have any have any
reason to go to it so again what's
Batman sort of regains his sanity kind
of comes back you know really sort of
returns to himself so apologies are
given back and forth between himself and
Alfred and Batman basically explains
this is what I have to do because
there's no other way that I can win
there's no conceivable way that I can
beat this guy and now the cool thing is
that following this we're bad that's
kind of racing through the city it gives
us a chance to sort of see how this
visor impacts him right like when he
goes through there and he uses this
visor he looks around and he sees like
people who were hopeful like basically
like good people he sees their dreams
what they what they look to aspiring uh
parents who hope that their child
becomes something great in the world but
then like what he also sees is the
darker side people who want to murder
each other who want to like pillage and
destroy each other but it's kind of a
cool scenario where this visor working
the way it does
with the nature of Gotham City and the
question I would pose to you is which
one of these is the truth
the version where like Batman sees
hopeful people or the people who are
violent and destructive and just want to
kill everything which one of these is
true when it comes to the realm of
Gotham because Gotham is a dark and
violent place and it's kind of
interesting because it's kind of Scott
Snyder sort of asked him that question
like which one of these is real like
which one of these is the actual real
place now at this point we actually
switch over to Commissioner Gordon's son
right Louis which we switch over to
James Gordon jr. and again we talked
about him in previous videos that James
Gordon was a legitimate psychopath but
with Batman bringing him out as kind of
using his mind to kind of predict where
the Batman who last will go kind of
using a crazy person to predict a crazy
person more or less but as he's talking
to James you know one of the things that
James asked it really kind of makes us
this argument on his Batman's no kill
rule and one of the things he says is
that back when he was a psychopath and a
serial killer that he was kind of like
the no kill rule is stupid because like
all Batman really seems to do with his
no kill rule is give criminals a second
chance but he's giving criminals a
second chance to commit crimes the only
way to really deal with criminals and to
get rid of them completely is to kill
them a dead man cannot be a repeat
offender and it's kind of a cool thing
because when when he says that it's sort
of hey look like this is how I view the
world
I thought your Nokia will was stupid
because all you were doing was just
basically letting criminals back out on
the street you had this sort of you know
really hopeful gosh golly they'll repent
one day you know kind of kind of belief
system but it never did any good you
were a gerbil in a hamster wheel you
were just running in circles hoping
things changed one day if you run long
enough or run hard enough but they never
really do but what he also says is at
the same time one of the things that
I've learned is that there are people
out there who deserve second chances
it's not that clear-cut
not everyone deserves a second chance
but not everyone deserves to die for
what they did you kind of have to take
it on a case-by-case situation what he
asks is he says hey look I know what
you're trying to do here and I get where
you're going with this the question I
have is what's the Batman who laughs is
defeated and when you defeat him do you
have a failsafe do you have a way to
bring yourself back and to basically
cure yourself of this joker toxin and
Batman doesn't answer and so the
implication seems to be that know that
once he becomes the Batman who laughs
there's no way to undo this so he's
going to be stuck this way the fact
remains that what this ends up doing
it's kind of switching to like three
hours prior and we have this awesome
this awesome side where that takes place
between Batman and Joker and it's so
cool because when Batman spins around
and starts talking to Joker like again
he kind of hallucinates that like Joker
wants to kill
so on and so forth but what the Joker
says is like I'm just here to talk and
when that mess was asking questions like
could you just want to talk you want to
laugh do you want to see like that you
finally got what you wanted the Joker
says no this is not what I wanted I did
not want you to become the Batman who
laughs that if anybody's gonna kill you
I want it to be me more so than that
like you and I are intertwined forever
like it's kind of crazy because it's
like we are sort of irrevocably tied
together right like you know I'm the the
Clown Prince of Crime like on the
ultimate evil you try to be the ultimate
good even though you're not really and
like we fight against each other and
that's basically it
but he basically says that like this is
really the only way that you could win
Riley this is the only way that you
could possibly pull it off but you know
I believe that one day like I will kill
you and that will be the end of that but
until that day comes I came here to
simply tell you good luck and it's kind
of interesting here because what Batman
does is he addresses the Joker and he
says look the people in my life like
Alfred will not have the cojones to do
what it takes right like if I full-on
become the Batman who laughs like if
there's no way to bring me back from
becoming the Batman who lasts
Commissioner Gordon Alfred like none of
these guys will have the have the balls
to do what it takes so I need you to do
that and the Joker says yes if you
become a Batman who laughs I will kill
you it's a mercy killing it's really
Batman like relying on the Joker like I
wouldn't go as far as you say like they
become friends but they become more
allies than anything else so again like
trying to track down these these portals
trying to try and track down these
sources Batman is a traveling the
Blackgate prison to the section that was
really more of like a transition period
right like it was basically like a
halfway house so to speak between those
being brought in and then being sent to
Arkham Asylum and so as he goes through
here he ends up running into like this
one cop you know who's kind of like hey
look you're the bad man who laughs I'm
gonna blow your head off and that man
basically reasons with him and kind of
reveals information like his wife and
his daughter his daughter has a little
little bit a little Batman doll that she
squeezes and at last which of course
Batman never laughs Batman doesn't like
the fact that it last and so he's kind
of like hey look that's how you know I'm
Batman because I don't laugh you know
and it is kind of funny it's kind of a
cool little thing but still like as he
goes through this portal he ends up in
this version of Blackgate that's six
times the size of the one in the main DC
Universe and we end up finding out that
in this one particular universe in the
dark multiverse that this version of
Arkham Asylum is ran by Bruce Wayne
himself and in this moment like when he
starts addressing him and saying hey
look like you're in danger people are
gonna come here they're gonna try to
take you and they're going to try to
eliminate you again we don't really know
the reason why these different Bruce
Wayne's are being killed being taken and
killed but we do know Batman is trying
to save this one and
that moment they're yanked back in the
main DC Universe and where Batman tries
to take this version of Bruce and
basically hands them over to to this
conference as they look keep an eye on
him make sure nothing happens to him and
then in turn deals with like the other
officers who were showing up we end up
finding out this cop is not actually a
cop instead this cop is the Batman who
laughs and that's crazy because
basically like it's set it's set Batman
up and it's kind of a cool thing because
what he says is like I know everything
that you're going to do that man who
laughs knows everything Bruce Wayne is
going to do and that's the difference
here is that Bruce Wayne is basically
like he transformed himself into the
Batman who laughs but he's not actually
thinking like the Batman who laughs he's
thinking like Bruce Wayne and so it's
basically Snyder kind of saying hey look
you're really gonna have to give
yourself over and become this dark and
sinister version with a tiny ounce of
yourself governing your actions in order
to fully be able to defeat this guy
otherwise like there's no real way for
you to win and so what the Batman who
laughs does masquerading as this cop as
he tells all the other officers that
Batman is that Batman who laughs he
basically killed Bruce Wayne he's got a
trigger device he's gonna blow himself
and everybody else up kill him take him
out now and all the other officers
around them opened fire on Batman okay
so we are covering the Batman who laughs
part five and again like like the Batman
who laughs is solid I guess it's one of
the coolest things but in the in the
last video that we had the way we kind
of left off was that the Batman who
laughed essentially like tricked these
cops at Arkham Asylum into believing
that like the actual Batman was the
Batman who last and again this is kind
of a kind of a cool uh cool scheme
because what better way to make an
escape then a look at your current
circumstance and then finding out that
way right like it's the best way to do
it it's the art of war by Sun Tzu right
like don't fight on there toward a
territory fight on your territory
use your skills against the Batman
undertook the the task of becoming the
Batman who laughs in order to figure out
a way to defeat him and in doing so
almost engineer his own demise and this
this this first bit of the comic really
picks up with him just being like shot
at by all these cops and the Batman who
last teleporting away and Batman tries
to reason with him but but remember
because he's sort of turning into his
evil counterpart what this means is that
this darker side is beginning to take
hold a little more than it had before
now it's an internal struggle that's
constantly going on between the two of
them but the idea here is he says okay
look there's a part of me that just
wants to kill these guys and be done
with it but I can't
he was basically fleeing for his life
now because it suits Kevlar it makes it
almost impossible for them to basically
penetrate so then they start
in like armor-piercing rounds now here's
a kind of crazy thing here is the way
this is happening the way this is going
down it's kind of difficult for a Batman
to differentiate between what's actually
happening and what's not actually
happening because remember he's
basically you know using a mask of the
Batman who lasts he sees people's darker
intentions and he hears what he wants to
hear and so what this means is that he's
hearing them say things like shoot for
the mouth you know we can't we can't
penetrate his suit so this shoot him in
the mouth who's always made sense one
other shoe Batman in the throat but the
question that's kind of being asked here
is are they really saying that or does
Batman believe they're saying that and
the implication is that it goes either
way from there Batman realizes the only
way to really make an escape is to
pretend to be the person they fear so
much and that's exactly what he does he
sits down he says okay fine it's my only
out here so he starts running off the
names in the addresses and all the
things that he knows about these cops
that are familiar to him and basically
says if you do not let me leave here I
will find you I will track you down and
I will kill everyone and everyone you
ever met like I'll kill you and
everybody that you ever met here and
it's cool because it scares them out of
their wits and he says I'm the Batman
who laughs follow me down if you want to
and then basically makes his escape and
that's kind of the cool thing here is
because Batman's not actually becoming
the Batman who laughs he's pretending
but it allows him to kind of tie into
that character it works both ways
if the Batman who laughs can use Bruce
Wayne as his own means of escape by
basically treating everybody to believe
in that Bruce Wayne is actually the
Batman who laughs then Bruce Wayne can
build on that use that to his own ends
it's one of the ways to show that
Batman's very quick on his feet but for
here of course it really kind of catches
Commissioner Gordon making his escape
this is one of the things that's kind of
interesting is because when it comes to
like the little Robins that the Batman
who last had at his disposal we never
really knew who they were or where they
were from what we're actually told here
is these are all different versions of
the son of Jim Gordon now in reality I
would probably say that this is kind of
Scott Snyder just throwing it out there
that there was never really any
intention to explain where they came
from so just kind of tied in to the
story and then to say well they're all
your versions of you know all the
versions of your son Jim Gordon from
like different places in the dark--
multiverse but it's cool because it's a
way to torment Jim Gordon I remember
this is basically like the Punisher
Batman more or less whose people you can
calm whatever you want to you know but
like its Punisher Batman
more or less it is really what it is but
basically it's him just kind of
tormenting Jim Gordon remember the
vendetta between the two is really only
one-sided that in the the university
comes from the grim Knight
is basically a guy who was like defeated
by Jim Gordon he was a vigilante
Punisher Batman who was eventually
caught up to in defeated by Jim Gordon
and Jim Gordon's eyes he's just kind of
a kind of a crazy guy in a maniac but in
the grim Knights eyes is hey like you
you defeated me in your universe so I'm
gonna defeat you in yours it's kind of a
twisted sort of scenario but again in
the midst of all this is Jim Gordon
making his escape he's caught up to by
his son and basically you know his son
kind of helps him get out of there and
and you know recover and so on but from
here we switch over back to the Batman
who laughs in one of the coolest parts
of the story because the questions asked
like why have you come here and it's
like well I came here because I wanted
to address you because I wanted to talk
to you because I have a small favor you
know and so on and so forth and it's
kind of kind of this disembodied voice
and as soon as I heard that as soon as I
saw that I was like okay he's talking to
the court of owls and that's exactly
what it is it's one of the coolest
things the Batman who laughs meets the
court of owls and this is awesome
because the court of owls is like this
really clandestine organization that ran
Gotham behind the scenes we know that
from Scott Snyder's run on the new 52
Batman and it's so cool to see him kind
of wrap back around than what he
originally created and sort of tie it in
to the cons to the content going forward
it's awesome now the funny thing about
this is that the court of owls
traditionally allows the youngest member
of the court to choose what's going to
happen to a particular person who's
either been brought there or who has
strayed into the path of the owls and
doesn't really know what they're getting
into and so the youngest person
basically comes out you know you
literally have the Batman who lost she
says hey look you know all I have is a
small favor less that's all I really
have you know and the youngest person
says no no we're not giving you anything
we're gonna take you out and so what
ends up happening is they basically say
like the talons are gonna kill you now
of course those of you guys who are
unfamiliar with the court of owls the
town's are basically their henchmen
they're the people they send after you
to either kill you or bring you to the
court or whatever the case is but that's
what the Batman who lasts says but
that's the thing though guys like I've
already talked to your talons and I've
removed their arms this is how crazy
that Batman who lasts is how dangerous
he is he gets in there and says okay
what's the most immediate threat to me
if I walk into where the court of owls
aren't okay well then the most immediate
threat is the talents but Batman who
lasts is not walking into this blind and
that's cool because what he says is that
in another universe in the dark
multiverse because of how extreme you
guys were and how crazy you guys were
there was a kind of respect between
yourself and like Bruce Wayne and so in
an alternate in a in a dark multiverse
there was a time when Bruce Wayne took
over the court of owls and he became
the head of the court the new town and
he controlled everything and so like I'm
well aware of who you guys are I know
what you guys are about you guys are
just rich folks you guys use talents to
do your bidding but when your talents
are gone what are you guys you're
nothing you're you guys are weak you
guys are you guys can't do anything on
your own
without people protecting you it's kind
of interesting and so of course this
leads directly to like the arrival of
this Batman from the dark multiverse who
took over the court of owls facing off
against like the Batman who laughs now
of course he's defeated pretty quickly
and so what we do is we switch back over
to Batman enter to Jim Gordon now the
cool thing about this is that remember
one of the big talking points here was
the last laugh program right like the
idea that basically this this could be
activated and initiated and it would cut
Gotham Gotham off from like the rest of
the world right like it would cut him
off or cut it off from the rest the
united states water electricity the
whole nine yards everything would be cut
off and Gotham would become a totally
self-contained ecosystem and Batman's
plan with Commissioner Gordon was to do
that was to activate the last laugh
program to cut Gotham off to make sure
that nothing that that man who lost put
in the waterways could be expanded and
and basically extended out into the rest
of the country but that's when Batman
begins to think well that's what the
Batman who laughs wants it's kind of
crazy it's kinda like what what if this
is what he wanted all along what if what
the Batman who last one and all along
was for gosselin to be closed off was
for Gotham to become its own source of
power for Gotham to be isolated and
removed from everything and to become
its own place but if he did then the
question is why and that's when he gets
a call from the Batman who laughs and
he's told do not answer that call do not
respond to that call where he kind of
takes his hand off the device and says
no no you know we we will we will give
it a minute or two you know cuz you got
a two-minute countdown right like once
once over the first hand is put on there
it takes a to hand system once the first
hand is put on there you've got two
minutes in order to activate the whole
thing and that's when he basically says
okay let's see where this goes let's see
what happens with this he's talking
about man who lost the Batman who laughs
says you don't understand the true basis
behind Gotham now this is kind of a cool
thing there will be those who will kind
of look at that and say oh man here we
go again bat doesn't know everything
about Gotham whatever like the cool
thing about this is I love the idea this
Scott Snyder introduces this idea that
Batman doesn't know as much about Gotham
as he thinks he does and that's what's
so awesome is because what it does is
almost kind of paints Batman in this
light of being arrogant did Batman
you're not as smart as you believe you
are and that's what the Batman who lasts
basically says that the way that Gotham
was originally built the way it was
original
design Gotham was designed to be a seat
of power the Gotham was designed to be a
city where the person who ruled it could
essentially extend their influence out
to the rest of the world in a myriad of
different ways you could cut it off you
could shut it off from the rest of the
world and you could say like Gotham is
totally isolated and alone and this is
awesome because again like it gives like
whoever it is it controls Gotham or
who's who's sitting on Gotham if this
last life program is operated will
essentially be able to like operate
outside of the United States and do
their own thing like you can poison the
rest of the world and Gotham will be
fine and that's kind of the cool thing
here is because one is up happening is
like Batman liz is literally being
talked to you by Jim Gordon they're
saying like don't listen Alfred Alfred's
coming in offers chiming in don't listen
and Batman can't help but listen Batman
can't help but hear what's going on and
and what he ends up doing is actually
agreeing with the Batman who laughs so
that man who laughs says like press the
button put your hand cut Gotham off from
the rest of the world let Gotham be what
it's supposed to be let it be it's
darker side and Alfred is kind of crazy
Alfred chimes in for a second and says
hey look like you're not us we'll see
this year you are the living heart of
Gotham you're the guy that tries to make
the city a better place and Batman has
responses and it hasn't worked he's not
fixing anything and so what what is up
happening is like in the final moments
of this Batman puts his hand on the
machine and basically follows through
with the plan of the Batman who laughs
and shuts down the entire connection
between Gotham and everything else and
so essentially Batman has joined the
Batman who last and it's pretty awesome
like it's it's pretty solid okay so we
are getting back into dark nights not
dark nights metal the Batman whoo laughs
and again like in the last video that we
had we were talking about the nature of
like the last laugh protocol right and
how Batman had activated it now for
those who guys who were catching up the
last laugh protocol was a protocol
designed by Batman for the purpose of
like cutting off Gotham from the rest of
essentially like the world right like
just totally isolating the city in its
entirety in case something happened like
the Joker decided to release Joker toxin
into the water system or something like
that Batman could activate it and keep
the toxin from spreading throughout like
the rest of the country the surrounding
cities different things like that and so
because of the because of the whole
situation the way it's unfolding when
Batman activated this did it suddenly
turn into okay
Batman's basically sighted against
everyone and that was kind of where we
were left right
we were left with this idea the Batman
is sighted against like like everybody
and he had basically joined the Batman
who lasts and that's kind of the funny
thing because we you have Alfred in his
ear telling him hey look like your
toxicity levels are getting super-high
if you keep doing what you're doing like
if you go into any kind of situation
that heightens your adrenaline then
you're gonna switch over to the Batman
who laughs right because your cells are
almost completely irradiated with his
whole formula and you're gonna end up
turning into him and that's when Batman
kind of chimes in and says no no no I
didn't activate this because I'm
becoming the Batman who lasts I
activated this because it's the only
chance we have and that's kind of the
cool thing because then you have the son
of Commissioner Gordon who comes in and
says yeah it basically buys us time now
remember the son of James Gordon yo
James Gordon jr. is basically crazy at
like a serial killer right and so
bringing him in here it's kind of big
it's kind of Batman's way of being able
to see into the eye of a crazy person
but the issue with this is that as
Batman has slowly started to become the
Batman who laughs what is done is this
kind of altered his perspective to where
he can sort of see directly into his
mind and not not literally but insofar
as functioning akin to him and how he
thinks and that's what he says I pretty
much am him like I almost am a Batman
who lasts I know his one real weakness I
know where all of this is leading to and
so what this does is it allows them to
essentially set a trap taking over the
entirety of the power grid and allowing
it only to really be controlled from
from from the Batcave what it means is
like they're the only person that can do
anything with it now of course Batman
also acknowledges that the grim knight
right like the Punisher bat for Batman
from an alternate reality can basically
like hack into the power grid and do
whatever it is they need to do but it'll
take time to achieve that which buys
them time they didn't have before and so
again it's kind of a cool little moment
because we basically switch over to like
an alternate reality when you end up
having like some version of Bruce Wayne
they basically bought everything right
like literally bought everything in
Gotham City like everything runs under
under like the funding of Bruce Wayne
like he privates privatized the entire
like all the city services the police
the fire department the whole nine yards
and where somebody could do that and use
it for nefarious ends he actually did it
for it for basically a benefit
essentially saying like so long as my
company makes money you guys will be
funded you're no longer relying on
taxpayer dollars which means taxpayer
dollars can actually be used towards
things they can truly benefit society as
opposed to just you know funding cops
and all that kind of good stuff and so
as a result of that we end up having
this alternate reality version of Batman
that basically vanishes right it's also
the reality version of Bruce that just
kind of gets whisked away when the
Batman who laughs
those who take him out and of course
that's when he really kind of chimes in
and says that is Bruce Wayne who did it
now following this is a really really
cool exchange that takes place between
Commissioner James Gordon and his son
James Gordon jr.
and jr. tries to like talk to his father
right and almost seems to try to make
that you know pitch this case that when
it's all said and done and they're you
know in the end the smoke clears that
like they should consider setting him
free and the response of Jim is no
because I just don't trust you because I
think you're still crazy I think you're
still insane like the like all
indications here are that he still
believes his son is a villain that he'll
try to get him the help he needs he'll
try to make sure they're treated fairly
but it's like he doesn't view him as his
own son he views him as like a criminal
he happens to be working with that seems
to share the same name as him and it's
one heck of a way for a father to view a
son in a way that's almost kind of like
hopeless it's pretty dark and is pretty
twisted and is pretty grim but from
there again we kind of switch back over
to Batman in this fight he has with the
Batman who laughs and this is kind of a
cool moment because when when Bruce
Wayne shows up here of course the Batman
who laughs is hot on his trail and
basically says hey like like you know
bruises like I knew you're gonna be here
and Batman who laughs is like yeah I
knew you're gonna be here too and you're
slowly but you know turning into me and
it's almost kind of like mind games and
that's one of the things that you don't
really see when it comes to Bruce Wayne
when it comes to him like like toying
with people it's usually based on fear
right it's usually based on the idea of
like I'm going to use fear to try to
overcome you so it is mind games insofar
as he plays on people's psychological
perspective of like fear and all that
kind of good stuff but with a Batman who
laughs he's really more just maniacal
and so seeing him play mind games with
Bruce Wayne like yes man you're becoming
me like you're slowly turning into me
there's nothing you can do about it you
know like you believe you have this
great big huge grandiose plan set but I
promise you this was all according to me
like everything that's happening here is
is happening because I wanted it to you
it's kind of a cool little exchange now
we know the Batman who last really loves
doing that I mean we've seen from the
stories you know the way the stories
have been written that he loves focusing
and kind of messing with people's
individual minds he talks about things
like killing the entire bat family you
know when you had like Bruce Wayne who
was kind of like you know I guess when
when he was sorting into the Batman who
last when the toxin first began to
infect him it was kind of like okay I
can maintain my sanity I can maintain
Who I am and and all it takes is the
smallest push the smallest nudge over
the edge kind of a homage to to you The
Killing Joke with all it takes is one
bad day and so what he ends up saying
here is that like hey when it came to
the bat family in my universe where I
come from I wanted to make sure they
were aware of what was going on so I
invited them over for tea
and setting the T out was enough of an
adrenaline push to push me over the edge
and when they showed up I killed them
all it's just it's it's little things
like that right like just kind of like
this is how twisted and screwed up
you're gonna become and there's nothing
you can do about it there's nothing you
can do to stop it and so following that
we yell again kind of switching back
over to Commissioner Gordon and James
Gordon jr. we get this really cool
segment right we're like they entered
into the bat armory and then of course
when they come out in the grim Knights
they're kind of going crazy and doing
all kinds of bonkers stuff they end up
busting out with like these Batman
Beyond costumes and it looks so amazing
like it's it's it's pretty badass I'm
almost inclined to call this like the
Batman who lasts beyond right like
because it's it's so cool to see like
these little these little homage is
right because when you're Scott Snyder
and you're sitting down and you're
writing a story about the Batman mythos
it's huge in its expansive right and
Batman Beyond is a is a beloved show for
a lot of people right they grew up
watching that show they thought it was
amazing I'm curious like like how much
do you guys love Batman Beyond I'm kind
of curious about that because it was
after my time but a lot of you guys
really seemed to enjoy it I mean it's
pretty cool play it is a pretty cool
concept but again like they're showing
up here with the intention of being able
to take out the grim Knight they
actually get dealt with pretty quickly
right in and assume that they're kind of
taken out pretty fast but it is a cool
moment because what you have are these
kind of battles going on in two fronts
right you've got you've got the grim
Knight versus Jim Gordon because
remember in the grim Knights reality he
was defeated by Commissioner Gordon so
he kind of holds a grudge against
seemingly anybody who's Commissioner
Gordon in any universe regardless of
where it is and then of course you've
got Batman and you've got the Batman who
lasts but between the grim nine and Jim
Gordon what he does is kind of hit on
him and say hey man like you're not as
great as you think you are in my reality
you gave up on your son but you look at
your son as a person who couldn't be
fixed who was incorrigible essentially
everything that you're saying now about
your son is all the things that you said
in my universe so yeah you're as crappy
as I think you are you're nowhere near
as great as you believe you are and it's
kind of a cool thing it's kind of a cool
moment because what it does is it puts
it in a perspective that like Jim Gordon
really liked kind of you know harkening
back to the things he said to his son is
not that great of a human being he just
kind of gave up on his son which is
something that no person should ever
kneel no parent should ever give up on
their child as it was kind of like what
kind of a parent is he really
now again of course the fight between
Batman and the Batman who lasts I think
is a lot more desperate because in this
fight what you have here is essentially
Batman not really fighting the the
Batman who lasts so much as fighting to
become that version of himself right I
mean because it's the one
he seems to be the most terrified of
becoming some twisted version of himself
this bent by nothing but chaos and evil
and all it wants to do is just like
inflict as much damage death and
destruction as it can like Batman's
terrified of that the Joker takes hold
basically and like he's infected
forevermore and like having an earth
where there's two Batman who laugh
running around there would be bonkers
like I mean you're talking about
probably the death of the Justice League
you're talking about the deaths of most
of the superheroes because you have all
the ingenuity and all the intelligence
of Batman combined with all the insanity
and the chaotic nature of the Joker and
then you double that and then you set it
loose on the superhero community what
hope does anybody have right so like
Batman's not just fighting for himself
he's kind of fighting for the world in a
lot of different ways and that's really
when he kind of hits heady you know when
the Batman who laughs talks about a lack
of hope and he says you have no real
hope here and there's nothing you can
really do to win the response of Bruce
is I have one hope like like I found a
universe where there is a version of
Bruce Wayne that is hopeful well there
is a version of Bruce Wayne that hasn't
given up yet that hasn't like gone down
this dark path that I've set myself on
and it's basically the child version of
himself from a different universe and of
course this version comes running in and
Bruce's like hey go with them go take
off to the Batcave it's designed to be
hopeful and that's kind of the crazy
thing because what this does is it seems
to hit it the idea that Bruce Wayne
expects to die that bring that version
of himself over into the universe will
basically lead to him dying where that
khana seems to be the case now again I
doubt that's exactly what will happen
but it's almost kind of like Bruce Wayne
is expecting that right because it's
like okay I'm probably gonna die in this
fight and if I do somebody else used to
carry on the the Batman mantle and
there's a version of myself out there I
want him to have the life that I never
had for myself right like almost kind of
like a parent of sorts and so it's cool
to see this this little a little bit of
a scenario play out and so again like I
get real with Commissioner Gordon and
with the grim Knight Commissioner
Gordon's basically toppled he's
essentially taken out it kind of goes
back and forth and back and forth and so
when this last little bit of the story
where things begin to kind of close out
the Batman who laughs ultimately gets
the upper hand and like going to attack
Bruce Wayne he manages to subdue him
grab a serum he has in his possession
and inject it into Bruce Wayne
essentially turning Bruce Wayne into the
Batman who lasts it's one of the coolest
things like it's one of the most awesome
things ever and I am hyped for this so
again a relatively short issue really
more action than anything else but it's
pretty solid
okay so we are getting into the madmen
who last part seven okay what we've
really covered up to this point is we
were basically talking about like the
near collapse of Gotham City right and
those of you guys who read Batman in
game this felt a lot like it right and
that's one of the reasons why it for the
foreseeable future people will usually
reference that story because there were
stories that came before in game like
Batman no man's land of different things
like that but in game was like this
first real big instance that we saw
where a singular villain managed to
almost completely topple the entirety of
Gotham City and in fact Joker did he
suppose the entire city of Gotham to the
Joker toxin and drove the whole town
insane so it was kind of a question of
how in the world can Batman possibly
pull that off now again it was it was it
was cool in terms of how Joker was
defeated and how it all came to an end
and the fight between himself and Batman
that kind of led to their respective
deaths which allowed Commissioner Gordon
to take over Batman
during the DCU initiative but the idea
behind this is is really kind of Scott
Snyder drawing on what he's done before
and that's really where this sort of
picks up right at me at this moment
you've basically got the idea of the the
kind of initiative the Batman set in
motion that would cut Gotham off from
like the rest of the world right like if
it was initiated basically it would take
water from the various locations around
Gotham and he would dump it into the
rest of the city and essentially
quote-unquote try to fix it it would
isolate Gotham you know from the rest of
the world basically he'd be totally cut
off and it was a Batman who laughs using
this as a means to basically turn Gotham
City upside down now the reason why this
is so significant and the reason why
that's really differs from the events of
Batman's Batman in game is because
Batman in game was a result of the Joker
toxin right and like Batman's found
cures for that there's always a way to
cure that with us the the really the
serum of the Batman who laughs there's
no real cure for it nobody knows how to
get rid of it right so if he succeeded
and he did the exact same thing the
Joker did he would destroy Gotham and
that's one of the things that Scott
Snyder had kind of been hitting on and
basically trying to tell us like look if
the Batman who laughs wins there's no
turning back right you can't unring that
Bell it's all over for the city of
Gotham and so it's basically in Batman
trying to stop him ever since but with
Batman having been exposed to the serum
he's been slowly losing his mind and
becoming the Batman who laughs and that
kind of leads to the fight between the
two of them that's taking place here in
this cemetery more or less now remember
the idea of this child version of Batman
being here let's talk about him here in
a second but the idea of this child
Batman being here is really that Batman
who last brought him here for the sake
of taunting Bruce and of course you know
taking out the kid but what is up
happening here is about when you last
basically says hey look I've got
the serum and basically I've got this
this light on here when this light turns
red it means you're fully changed and
then like you gotta go so it's basically
kind of a countdown timer to the end of
Bruce and it's this cool little moment
because when this plays out like when
this happens it's really more of a Bruce
trying to play the game with the Batman
who lasts and trying to use
psychological warfare to win ultimately
doesn't really work but it's kind of a
cool little moment because he's sort of
like okay cuz you got the Batman who
laughs standing here pointing a gun in
his head and saying like once this is
done like I have this kid here this
kid's gonna be infected he's gonna be my
quote unquote offspring for lack of a
better word he's gonna carry on the
mantle of everything that I've done uh
and and like you're gonna do the exact
same thing in this universe and Batman's
kinda like Jess man he's gonna kill
himself
this is awesome this works he's like
yeah I'll do it man I'll do it and of
course we end up finding out the Batman
who laughs was playing the joke and it
was kind of a cool thing because what
Bruce had done here is in these little
vestiges it's well the reasons why Scott
Snyder is so good at writing Batman is
Bruce had thought of almost everything
of pretty much everything in this
circumstance right like the everything
that the Batman who laughs is is Bruce
Wayne and the Joker right so the Batman
who lasts would do what Bruce Wayne does
and in fact will actually see Batman
pick up on this and and use this to his
advantage with a plan that he had
concocted later on in the story but
basically what he done is he had used a
piece of Wayne tech inside his own suit
to turn the device read basically
tricking trying to trick the Batman who
lost into believing that like it's time
for him to go right like he can just
like shoot himself because everything's
taken care of now and all that kind of
good stuff
and of course Batman who lost catches
you know it catches up to it so right
off the bat that kind of gets snuffed
but again this is what Snyder's hitting
on with regards to the relation between
the two
everything Bruce Wayne could think of
the Batman who laughs has thought of and
that's why Snyder always told us about
man who laughs is the most dangerous foe
that Batman's ever faced none of those
villains think the way the Bruce Wayne
does none of them like know what his
moves would be before he makes them and
then knows how to counter them that's
why Batman who laughs is so dangerous
because he is Bruce Wayne he's just
Bruce Wayne from a different universe
their lives unfolded almost the exact
same way up to the point where their
parents died and then the Batman who
laughs basically snapped and then his
whole origin story unfolds so it's cool
to see this this whole scenario take
place here but it's this cool little
moment because while all this is going
on remember you also have Commissioner
Gordon and his son facing off against
the grim Knight I call him Punisher
Batman because that's basically what he
is ah but it's kind of a cool thing
because remember the grim Knight comes
through a universe where his version of
Commissioner Gordon defeated him his
version of Commissioner Gordon managed
to get the upper hand on him and took
him out so he's kind of harboring a
grudge here it's really one of these
things with a bad
whoo laughs is what if you could come to
a universe where I could destroy that
version of Bruce Wayne and you could
destroy that version of Commissioner
Gordon the grim Knight was on board he
was like I'm down right so that's kind
of why the grudge exists between the two
of them now remember the son of
Commissioner Gordon James is a serial
killer he's a psychopath
and so it's one of these things where
Commissioner Gordon's kind of working
reluctantly with his son but his son is
truly on a side here he's truly trying
to do the right thing you're essentially
watching two battles being fought at the
same time and so where you have these
drones that are showing up here they're
grabbing the water believing that it's
safe water and they're gonna take it to
Gotham City in order to basically ensure
that the water supply is pure so we
don't run into things like Batman in
game that's the whole reason why Batman
set this whole system in motion you end
up having Commissioner Gordon you know
kind of exposed to this water of course
you hold his breath but it's kind of a
crazy thing because in turn the grim
Knight basically says like we'd like I
know you're a psychopath I know you're
crazy I know you hate your father for
locking you away show him show your
father how much you hate him and in turn
like like literally James Gordon jr.
just sorts like stabbing away and it's
one of the craziest things right to see
this all go under well then you switch
back over to to Alfred and then you've
got you know Alfred kind of showing up
with with a machine gun and spraying
down the Batman whoo laughs we're not
really wishing a time machine again I'm
sorry with a shotgun and like spraying
down the Batman whoo laughs now it's
only a couple shots and it's kind of a
cool moment of course he doesn't really
kill him but this is the nature of
Alfred and this is one reason why Alfred
is so cool is because when you look at
his character in in the Batman comics
it's very easy to dismiss Alfred
Pennyworth as like the father figure
like the mentor guy but the important
thing about Alfred it's he is the Swiss
Army knife of the Batman family he can
do it all right he's a trained medic he
was in the military so right there he's
got all the medical and military
experience under his belt it's cool here
because when that all goes down Alfred
does what he can but then in turn the
Batman who laughs basically tells a
story of Alfred and he's like you don't
know about what happened to you on my
universe this is one of the darkest
points of the story right like the whole
Batman who last think it's one of the
most screwed up aspects the Batman who
laughs basically says like in my
universe I killed all those superheroes
that's true I killed everybody in the
Justice League
I killed Superman I literally twisted
everybody inside out and the entirety of
my universe either they're dead or
they're basically running around as
people who laugh whatever the case is
but you my friend you are still alive
basically what I did here is I took you
and I stuck you down in in like one of
the sub caves and I fed you scraps and I
kept you exposed to darkness you were
basically in like sensory deprivation
and I whispered
you and I talked to you and it took a
year but I broke you and you are my most
dedicated servant it's screwed up in
reality like that's a fate worse than
death right to spend a year being stuck
in a place that you can't escape from
that you can't really see out of being
tormented by nothing more than like the
fact that the entire bat family died and
you couldn't save your surrogate son
because he's the one doing all this and
then in turn eventually just kind of
snapping and breaking like it's it's got
to be a fate worse than death and so you
basically have Batman who shows up and
he basically starts fighting against the
Batman who lasts alongside Alfred and
this is when we get the plan of Batman
and this is one of those things when it
really kind of comes down to okay
Batman's always got a way out right it's
one of these things it wouldn't really
be much of a Batman story if he didn't
win right I mean Batman's always got a
way out oh yeah because it's a Batman
story I mean it wouldn't really be much
of a Batman comic if he died in the
first issue because he couldn't find a
way out but essentially what goes down
here is there's like these these uranium
tips hollowed hollowed harpoons and
basically like Batman fires a madame
anta at the batman who laughs
incapacitates him and is like the reason
why I did this like why they're all here
you know they're basically you know it's
electrical devices you know they're
essentially great big huge rivet huge
tasers but the reason why I did this is
I set traps in every single location
that was significant to me because I
knew that's where you would go and this
is one of the cool things because what
Snyder's kind of been showing here is
that in the entire fight between the
Batman who lasts Bruce Wayne's been on
defense but Batman who lost makes a move
and then Bruce Wayne counters and about
man who lost makes a move and then Bruce
Wayne encounters it's never really been
Bruce Wayne on the offensive where he's
it finally got the upper hand and is
taking it to the Batman who lasts that's
never been the case now it's really been
Snyder of building up the nature of the
Batman who laughs is saying this is why
he's so dangerous is because he's always
got the upper hand on Bruce and Bruce is
always against the ropes but it is kind
of a cool thing to finally see Bruce get
the upper hand on him because he
interned electrocutes the piss out of
him and then starts to be beating the
crap out of him with the gravestone of
his mom right with like Martha Martha
Wayne's gravestone what did you say that
name because it was done by a terrible
writer named Zack Snyder thanks Snyder
was a terrible screenwriter why would
anybody allow him to make a movie but
but nonetheless so with this whole thing
like this this this place it's it's cool
because what we end up learning is it
like the the person that James Gordon
jr. was stabbing was not Commissioner
Gordon it was actually too grim Knight
like he literally stabbed him to death
and it's kind of a cool theme because
what this shows is a couple things about
the grim life one it shows he's not
nearly as
capable as Batman - it shows he doesn't
have the foresight of Batman and three
he doesn't have the fighting prowess of
Batman right like he's a half-measure
it's interesting here because like the
grim knight he's taken out of the
picture like that some people may be
against that because he was written out
so quickly but in reality he was nothing
more than a henchman he was the Batman
who laughs equivalent to a Robin right
he was just kind of there and and just
sort of doing whatever he needed to do
in order to take them take him out and
that was basically yet but then you
basically follow up with like the
surprise victory because what is up
happening here as well Batman sort of
snaps and gives in to his darker half
and it's just like I love this idea of
just letting go and just tearing things
up by just wrecking the Batman who lasts
suddenly like he's saved by the Joker
who fires the shot in the Batman who
lasts and seems to kill it like seems to
take him out now in response to this the
entire drone systems also taken down and
it's all basically wiped clean and
everything sort of reset now with with
that being the case Gotham City's
basically saved and it kind of begs the
question what happened to the Batman who
lasts like is he dead it's kind of a
cool little thing here because what you
end up doing is basically following up
with Batman who lasts talking to Alfred
Pennyworth about two weeks after this is
all going down and what you end up
learning is that there were some
basically like a blood sample that was
taken from the kid version of Bruce
Wayne that was used to synthesize a
serum that could cure Bruce Wayne of his
you know Batman who laughs exposure and
the reason why is because with the
Batman who lost serum it was created in
the dark multiverse right so the only
cure available for it would come from
the dark multiverse and as kind of what
Batman says and it's kind of Scott
Snyder basically saying that essentially
saying hey look they were being created
in the main DC Universe I could use a
blood sample from an alternate reality
version of myself from just some other
universe out there and everything would
be okay
right but it's like trying to trying to
fit a square peg into a round hole the
only way to cure a dark multiverse
illness or disease is to find a cure in
the dark multiverse because it's almost
like a kind of genetic or I guess atomic
structure of how it works all I kind of
stuff it just kind of aligns oh well
that makes any sense you're right
hopefully it does it's kind of finicky
the way that it the way that it's done
here but essentially the Batman who last
has been taken and held captive and
exists under the Hall of Justice
as a prisoner now the reason why this
matters and the reason why it's
significant is it's not Scott Snyder
just kind of giving us a throw away
explanation it's Scott Snyder telling us
he can return at any point in time but
if he had killed the Batman who last
then he would be gone right because DC
doesn't really play it fast and loose
with death like Marvel does right like
once a character is dead they usually
stay dead for a pretty significant
amount of time it's not like more comics
where a character dies and then like six
issues later they'll bring them
back from you know by some hand-wavy
explanation you know Cosmic Cube or
Infinity Gauntlet or whatever it is they
wanted to be or they were never actually
dad it was a trick the whole time you
know they never really do that they've
done it sporadically like with Batman
you know Batman was supposed to have
died you know during Final Crisis when
he was hit by the Omega sanction of
Darkseid and then instead like he was
just time displace because Batman's too
popular to kill like it was it was just
different things like that and so it
worked for what it was because what you
end up having is Commissioner Gordon and
his son basically making amends kind of
getting together and saying hey look you
know let's let's see if we can work
forward from here ah but it's Bruce
Wayne basically sitting down with with
Alfred and saying hey look like oh I've
been thinking about everything the
Batman who laughs said right like
everything the Batman who laughs has
told me is this like he's traveled
around the multiverse and he's seen all
these different versions of myself and
his fort like from what he tells me I'm
the most ineffective one right like I'm
the loneliest one I'm the angriest one
on the most bitter one and I'm the one
that's done the least to make Gotham a
better place and his and it's cool
because woody what he does he looks
around he says that's right right and
that's kind of the funny thing is
because when you go through the Batman
who laughs and you see these alternate
reality verses of Bruce there's one
where Bruce Wayne used all his money to
basically make Gotham City a much better
place kind of like this speaking for the
world almost a metropolis others all
these different versions of Bruce Wayne
that have gone on to do great things the
version of Bruce and in the DC Universe
he sucks like he's like he's it's it's
the argument that I made before right
like he's done nothing to make Gotham
City better than what it was if anything
it's worse because now they're
supervillains were flying around and so
you've got like you got this this system
where you've got this super rich guy who
uses essentially like a paltry portion
of his money to create some building
somewhere and say this will be a beacon
for Gotham City and it never is you know
and then in turn uh he just runs around
at night and just beats up criminals
hoping they can change and it's just
kind of like you know sometimes it
doesn't work that way you know sometimes
hope just isn't enough doing things
changes things doing nothing keeps
things exactly the way they are and
that's kind of what Batman's done and
that's what he's saying in the story
like he's looking at that he's like I'm
ineffective like I'm not ineffective
superhero it's kind of a cool thing here
like it's it's like it's a cool
explanation and it's a cool discussion
that goes on now what this means going
forward is that it's kind of ushering
Batman into a new direction because if
Batman sits around and says everything
I've done to this point has been
ineffective in making Gotham City a
better place right like the Joker's
still there running around doing things
the penguins still doing things to face
Bane so on and so forth and in fact Bane
actually conquered the city if all this
is going on and I'm one step forward and
two steps back then like something
to change and so the idea here at least
what I hope comes out of it is that we
see kind of a new era of Batman where
either it's using his wealth to actually
do something that matters as opposed to
funding some building somewhere
hopefully something big kind of comes
out of that and hopefully it'll be kind
of cool but then what you also have kind
of the tail end of this and this is
where sort of continues on in a Batman
Superman number one is you basically
have Commissioner Gordon who's just sort
of out there and he's met by a rookie
and the guys like hey man are you okay
and commissioner Ian of finding out
Commissioner Gordon when he was pushed
face down into the water by the grim
knight was exposed to the toxin he's
going crazy he's essentially becoming
the Batman who lost it's kind of a cool
little moment there because it's the
idea that the legacy always lives on and
the legacy always continues well that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here two
comments explain make sure you guys have
the sub button to become part of the rod
for if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]